si Auguste hubiera estado viva hoy,
no podríamos darle a ella más ayuda que la que Alois le dio hace 114 años.
Alois era el Dr. Alois Alzheimer.
Y Auguste Deter, la primer paciente
en recibir un diagnóstico que ahora llamamos enfermedad de Alzheimer.
Desde 1901 la medicina ha avanzado mucho.
Se han descubierto antibióticos y vacunas
para protegernos de las infecciones,
muchos tratamientos para el cáncer, antirretrovirales para el VIH,
estatinas para las cardiopatías y mucho más.
Pero poco se ha progresado en el tratamiento del Alzheimer.
Soy parte de un equipo de científicos
que trabajan para encontrar una cura para el Alzheimer
desde hace más de una década.
Así que pienso en esto todo el tiempo.
El Alzheimer ahora afecta a 40 millones en todo el mundo.
Pero en 2050, afectará a 150 millones
que, por cierto, incluirá a muchos de Uds.
Si esperan vivir hasta los 85 años o más,
la posibilidad de contraer Alzheimer será casi uno de cada dos.
En otras palabras, existe la probabilidad de que pasen
sus años dorados con Alzheimer
o ayudando a cuidar a un amigo o ser querido con Alzheimer.
Ya solo en EE.UU.,
el cuidado de Alzheimer cuesta USD 200 000 millones cada año.
1 de 5 dólares de la asistencia médica se gasta en la enfermedad de Alzheimer.
Hoy es la enfermedad más costosa,
y sus costos prevén un aumento de cinco veces en el año 2050,
a medida que envejece la generación del baby boom.
Puede que les sorprenda, pero
el Alzheimer es uno de los mayores retos médicos y sociales de nuestra generación.
Pero se ha hecho relativamente poco para combatirla.
Hoy, 1 de las 10 primeras causas de muerte de todo el mundo,
el Alzheimer es la única que no se puede
prevenir, curar o incluso ralentizar su desarrollo.
Entendemos menos del Alzheimer que de otras enfermedades
porque hemos invertido menos tiempo y dinero en la investigación de la misma.
El gobierno de EE.UU. gasta 10 veces más cada año
en la investigación del cáncer que en el Alzheimer
a pesar del hecho de que nos cuesta más el Alzheimer
y causa un número anual similar de muertes como el cáncer.
La falta de recursos se debe a una causa más fundamental:
la falta de conciencia.
Porque esto es lo que poca gente sabe, pero todo el mundo debería:
El Alzheimer es una enfermedad, y podemos curarla.
Para la mayor parte de los últimos 114 años,
todos, incluso, los científicos, confunden Alzheimer con envejecimiento.
Pensamos que llegar a ser senil
en una parte normal e inevitable de envejecer.
Pero solo hay mirar una foto de un cerebro envejecido
saludable en comparación con el de un paciente de Alzheimer
para ver el daño físico real causado por esta enfermedad.
Además de desencadenar una severa pérdida
de memoria y habilidades mentales,
el daño al cerebro causado por el Alzheimer
reduce significativamente la esperanza de vida y es siempre mortal.
Recuerden, el Dr. Alzheimer encontró placas y ovillos extraños
en el cerebro de Auguste hace un siglo.
Durante casi un siglo, no sabíamos mucho sobre esto.
Hoy sabemos que están hechos de moléculas de proteínas.
Pueden pensar una molécula de proteína
como un pedazo de papel que se pliega como un origami.
Hay lugares en el papel que son pegajosos.
Y cuando se pliega bien, estos puntos pegajosos terminan en el interior.
Pero a veces las cosas salen mal, y algunos puntos pegajosos
se quedan en el exterior.
Esto hace que las moléculas de proteína se peguen entre sí,
formando grupos que pueden formar grandes placas y ovillos.
Eso es lo que vemos en el cerebro de pacientes con Alzheimer.
Hemos pasado los últimos 10 años en la Universidad de Cambridge
intentando entender cómo funciona esta disfunción.
Hay muchos pasos, y la identificación de qué paso bloquear es compleja,
como desactivar una bomba.
Cortar un cable podría hacer nada.
Cortar los demás puede hacer que la bomba explote.
Hay que encontrar el paso correcto que lo bloquea,
y luego crear un medicamento que lo haga.
Hasta hace poco, en su mayor parte
se han reducido los cables y esperado lo mejor.
Pero ahora hay un grupo diverso de personas,
médicos, biólogos, genetistas, químicos, físicos, ingenieros y matemáticos.
Y juntos, hemos logrado identificar un paso crítico en el proceso.
Ahora se está probando un nuevo tipo de fármacos que bloquean
específicamente este paso para detener la enfermedad.
Les mostraré algunos de nuestros últimos resultados.
Nadie fuera de nuestro laboratorio lo ha visto todavía.
Veamos unos videos de lo que sucedió al probar estos fármacos en gusanos.
Estos son los gusanos sanos,
y se puede ver que se mueven con normalidad.
Estos gusanos, por otro lado,
tienen moléculas de proteína que se pegan entre sí dentro de ellos,
como en humanos con Alzheimer.
Y se puede ver que están claramente enfermos.
Pero al dar nuestros nuevos fármacos a estos gusanos en una etapa temprana,
entonces vemos que sanan y viven una vida normal.
Esto es solo un resultado inicial positivo, pero la investigación como esta
muestra que el Alzheimer es una enfermedad
que podemos entender y curar.
Después de 114 años de espera,
hay esperanza real de lo que puede lograrse
en los próximos 10 o 20 años.
Pero para que crezca esa esperanza, de vencer el Alzheimer, necesitamos ayuda.
No se trata de científicos como yo,
se trata de Uds.
Debemos concienciarnos de que el Alzheimer es una enfermedad
y que si lo intentamos, podemos vencerla.
En el caso de otras enfermedades,
los pacientes y sus familias han encabezado más investigación
y ejercido presión sobre gobiernos, industria farmacéutica,
sobre científicos y legisladores.
Eso fue esencial para avanzar en el tratamiento del VIH a finales de los 80.
Hoy vemos esa misma unidad para vencer el cáncer.
Pero los pacientes de Alzheimer a menudo no pueden hablar por sí mismos.
Y sus familias, las víctimas ocultas,
cuidadores de sus seres queridos día y noche,
están a menudo demasiado desgastados para salir y abogar por el cambio.
Así que, realmente depende de Uds.
El Alzheimer no es, en la mayoría de casos una enfermedad genética.
Todo el mundo con un cerebro corre el riesgo.
Hoy en día, hay 40 millones de pacientes como Auguste,
que no pueden crear el cambio que necesitan para sí mismos.
Ayuden hablando por ellos,
y ayuden a exigir una cura.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)